[Musique]
oui et notre invité ce matin c'est
Julien Aubert bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vice-président des républicains on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale et le retour de Stéphane
Vernet de wouest France bonjour Stéphane
bonjourian bonjour Julien Aubert bonjour
bonjour on parle du projet de
laimmigration pour commencer évidemment
Julien Aubert qui est examiné au Sénat
depuis hier après-midi un texte ferme
mais pas fermé c'est ce que dit Gérald
armanin les Français qui sont favorables
à ce texte qui contient beaucoup de
mesures de durcissement est-ce que les
républicains peuvent le faire échouer
sans se décrédibiliser ah je pense qu'au
contraire il se
crédibiliserait en expliquant aux
Français à quel point ce texte a été mal
construit si je devais prendre une
métaphore vous avez une maison avec une
porte et vous décidez de la fermer hein
parce qu'on ferme les frontières bon
d'abord premièrement vous n'arriverez
jamais à la fermer parce qu'il y a une
cale ça c'est le problème de la
souveraineté c'est vous avez toujours
des problèmes de de cours de justice de
l'Union européenne de CEDH qui vous
interdisent véritablement de fermer la
porte mais en plus de ça vous mettez un
petit écrito c'est l'article 3 en disant
attention si la porte est fermée vous
pouvez passer par la porte de derrière
elle est ouverte la porte de derrière ce
sont des mécanismes qui permettent de
faire une immigration irrégulière
illégale vous rentrez par la porte de
derrière et là on vous fait un parcours
je dirais d'intégration en direct
puisque vous pouvez demander l'asile
c'est l'article 4 et immédiatement vous
pouvez travailler et l'article 3 on vous
dit explique que quand vous avez
travaillé 8 mois vous pouvez être
régularisé c'est fantastique c'està que
article 4 vous organisez le détournement
de la procédure d'asile article 3 vous
organisez une espèce de de blanchiment
d'immigration clandestine et donc les
Français qui veulent que la porte soit
fermée vous devez leur expliquer que un
le texte ne permet pas de fermer la
porte et de que le texte permet de faire
rentrer des gens chez vous alors le
texte est mal construit mais il peut
être encore reconstruit retricoté à la
fois par le Sénat par l'Assemblée est-ce
que à ce stade vous pensez qu'un
compromis est possible entre les
sénateurs les députés le gouvernement
les partis autour de ce fameux texte o
ça tout ça va se terminer par un 493 le
le sujet c'est pas de trouver un
compromis le sujet c'est de trouver un
texte qui soit fonctionnel et qui soit
cohérent enfin là c'est de trouver un
compromis autour de cet article 3 mais
depuis le non notamment avec les
sénateurs centristes depuis le début
attendez il y a il y a je dirais ce qui
relève du Sénat et ce qui relève de la
majorité présidentielle depuis le début
il y a un problème d'incohérence interne
de la majorité présidentielle ne sont
pas d'accord entre eux entre leur aelle
gauche et leur aelle droite donc comme
ils n'étaient pas d'accord entre eux ils
nous ont présenté un texte qui dit blanc
et noir dans la même copie et ensuite il
nous l'amène en disant merci de nous
aider à venir sur ce compromis qui n'en
est pas un puisque c'est un texte
antithéthique et et donc effectivement
je crois si vous voulez que c'est pas à
la droite de venir trancher nous il faut
qu'on vote ce qui est d'accord avec nos
opinions c'est-à-dire la fameuse porte
fermée et refuser de venir vider le
texte sa substance il y a pas qu'un
problème au sein de la majorité
présidentielle il y a aussi un problème
au sein de la majorité sénatoriale entre
les centristes et les républicains
autour de ce fameux article 3 est-ce que
les débats pourraient conduire à une
espèce de division une nouvelle fracture
au sein du groupe je crois que c'est
aussi une épreuve de vérité
effectivement pour la pour pour les gens
qui se réclament de la majorité
satoriale nous avons des élections à
venir bientôt dans 6 mois où Emmanuel
Macron sera le principal opposant d'une
droite qui est aujourd'hui dans le
position et je dirais il ne s'agit pas
d'être bête et méchant en disant parce
que ça vient d'Emmanuel Macron on est
contre il y a bien une règle de fond
derrière il y a il y a un sujet on peut
pas depuis des années expliquer que nous
avons un problème d'immigration
irrégulière expliquer que nous avons
déjà 500000 réfugiés sur notre
territoire nous avons 10 % d'étrangers
c'està direire le double de ce qu'il y
avait il y a 5 juste qu'on comprenne
bien Julien Bert quand vous dites moment
de vérité ça veut dire que vous demandez
au sénateurs centristes de clarifier
leur position par rapport à Emmanuel
Macron moi je suis pas en état si vous
voulez de réclamer quoi que ce soit au
Sénat c'est au sénateur si vous voulez
de voter en leur â et conscience mais je
crois qu'il ce serait une très un très
mauvais signal de voter un texte avec
cet article 3 parce que cet article 3 D
l'in même vidé de sa substance parce que
là il y a un compromis qui se dessine
sur un article 3 un peu un peu vidé de
sa substance attention alors là encore
on garde le parce que d'abord il y a a
je vois deux deux inconvénients à ce qui
est proposé actuellement premièrement
cet article 3 il faut voir que nous ne
vivons pas dans un monde clos il y a des
gens qui sont dans des pays
d'immigration qui ont la télé qui ont
Internet et qui suivent nos échanges et
ils sont souvent d'ailleurs mieux
informé que nous-même sur la nature des
débats et donc pourquoi c'est un article
qui est problématique parce qu'en fait
il dit venez en France nous avons des
besoins nous avons des métiers en
tention et si vous venez sur ces métiers
entention nous allons vous régulariser
c'est donc le fait paspirant et puis
deuxièmement parce que on veut mettre
dans la loi un mécanisme qui aujourd'hui
relève d'une circulaire ce qui va être
un nid à contentieux parce qu'à partir
du au moment où c'est fixé dans la loi
et que les préfets vont appliquer la loi
et bien vous aurez des recours alors
qu'une circulaire bien par définition
c'est une espèce de tolérance qui est
donné par rapport à l'état du droit
alors à propos des régularisations et
les préfets on général d'manin et le
ministre de l'Intérieur suspecté d'avoir
établi une liste des parlementaaires
républicains qui qui auraient écrit à
leur préfets pour leur demander de
régulariser les sans-piers dans leur
département Olivier marlex la semaine
dernière a dit qu'il voulait saisir
laaknil à ce à ce sujet contre le
ministre de l'Intérieur est-ce qu'il l'a
fait à votre à votre je ne suis pas au
courant sur ce point-là mais je pense
qu'effectivement ça pose un vrai sujet
parce que là encore on essaie de
diaboliser à titre personnel on peut
être ému par la situation de quelqu'un
qui est en situation irrégulière le
sujet n'est pas là moi je comprends le
restaurateur qui dit je travaille avec
quelqu'un et j'ai envie de lui donner
c'est c'est normal mais là on ne parle
pas de cas individuels on fait pas la
loi pour des cas individuels on fait la
loi pour des principes en même temps
s'il y a vraiment la moitié des
parlementaires LR sénateur ou députés
qui sont intervenus auprès de leur
préfet pour demander une régularisation
vous pouvez comprendre que le ministre
de l'Intérieur dit qu'il y a un problème
de de cohérence non on n jamais dit que
la droite n'a jamais dit nous sommes
hostiles à toute régularisation d'accord
en revanche nous sommes hostiles à
l'idée d'une régularisation automatique
qui dans le cas d'espèce va alors que
vous avez entre 600 et 900000
clandestins sur le territoire personne
n'est capable de chiffrer exactement
combien de régularisation cet article 3
va provoquer je vous rappelle qu'en 1980
le pic de régularisation c'était 130000
et que là on parle de 600 à 900000 à un
moment donné il faut être lucide vous
avez 64 74 % des Français qui trouvent
qu'il y a trop d'immigration dans ce
pays et on est en train de faire un
texte qui est qui va aller dans le sens
inverse Stéphane sur les mineurs
étrangers isolés oui on voit que les des
départements du du Sud-Est notamment
proche de l'Italie se se plaignent de
l'explosion du nombre de de mineurs
étrangers et isolers qui doivent être
pris en charge est-ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous avez constaté dans votre
dans votre propre département dans le
dans vos Cluses oui évidemment vous avez
on parle de plus en plus de filles oui
alors comment il y avec des garçons vous
confirmez aussi alors sur le sur le
genre non en revanche sur le fait que ce
soit un un vrai poids alors d'abord vous
avez quand même un phénomène de
détournement parce que vous avez des
gens qui se déclarent mineurs pour
pouvoir échapper à toute expulsion et
cetera et qui se trouve donc pris en
charge et puis deuxièmement
effectivement vous avez une recrud
d'esence parce que on sait aussi que le
régime est assez confortable et puis
parce que Ben vous avez des gens qui
fuient leur pays qui se réfugient qui
peuvent abandonner leur famille enfin
voilà donc effectivement et c'est ce
sont des montants financiers qui sont
particulièrement lourds pour des
départements comme celui du et c'est pas
lié aussi au fait que les les mineurs
isolés étrangers en fait qui qui
traversent la frontière sont plus
souvent interpellés aujourd'hui que par
le passé et donc systématiquement remis
au service d'aide à l'enfance de ces
départements ce qui était pas le cas
avant il traversaent on laissait passer
pour aller vers Lyon Paris Marseille ma
connaissance c'est un phénomène qui est
quand même plus ancien que je dirais
notre changement de politique aux
frontières puisque c'est ça fait
maintenant près de 10 ans hein si vous
regardez les articles mais les contrôles
aux frontières sont plus sont plus
strict sont plus fermes votre sens ou
pas on a oui il y a plus de contrôle au
frontière effectivement est-ce que on on
sent que vous êtes encore très ferme he
sur ce texte est-ce que les républicains
envisagent toujours de déposer une
motion de censure oui c'est la logique
et vous serez en mesure de le faire ah
ça c'est une autre chose mais la logique
c'est que si le Tex vient à l'inverse
vous savez parlons pas de détail parce
que vous allez m'attirer sur laaffaire
Bardella et je vais vous dire des choses
qui ne me plaisent pas qui vous plais
plairont pas ou qui leur plairont pas en
tout cas
sur sur cetteire de texte si
effectivement il y a l'article 3 si
effectivement il y a des choses qui sont
je dis dirais en contradiction et qui
sont un mensonge à l'égard des Français
sur la politique migratoire alors dans
ce cas-là c'est de notre devoir
effectivement de déposer une motion la
question de savoir ensuite oui non mais
est-ce que vous serez en capacité de le
faire je parce qu'on a l'impression que
les républicains sont quand même divisés
sur ce sujet vous pouvez pas savoir
combien de personnes seront pour déposer
une motion de censure tant que vous
n'avez pas le texte aujourd'hui on ne
sait même pas le texte qui va sortir du
Sénat même les sénateurs ne savent pas
donc allons-y par étape maintenant sur
le principe et tant éic SETI que Olivier
marlex ont réaffirmé leur volonté d'être
en capacité de déposer une motion de
censure et je pense qu'effectivement si
nous sommes en capacité de le faire il
faut le faire si ce texte sil y a une
cohérence il faut pas faire ou mais si
un texte qui sort du Sénat les
républicains de l'Assemblée le
suivront oucment ça voudrait dire que
d'abord il y a pas d'automaticité mais
effectivement ce sera plus compliqué
pour les républicains de l'Assemblée
nationale de le rejeter mais en revanche
il pourrait le modifier et puis
attention comme la majorité le
bariscentre n'est pas du tout le même un
texte sortirait du Sénat risque d'être
profondément reconfiguré à l'Assemblée
nationale et donc le texte sur lesquel
les députés vont voter ne sera sans
doute pas le même que celui du sorti du
Sénat et Mo vous me permettez de faire
un petit retour en arrière vous avez
évoqué la fire Bardella c'est quoi la
fire Bardella vous en avez trop dit ou
pas
assez j'ai vu hier si vous voulez que il
avait il avait expliqué que Jean-Marie
Le Pen n'avait jamais été antisémite
pour un homme qui a été condamné six
fois pour antisémitisme c'est peut-être
un détail pour lui mais pour moi ça veut
dire beaucoup ça veut dire quoi B ça
veut dire que on a le droit
effectivement d'expliquer que le
rassemblement national a rompu avec son
passé qu'il renit le Front national moi
je j'ai pas de jugement à faire sur je
sonne pas le cœur et les reins en
revanche aller jusqu'à une espèce
d'amnésie pour essayer de de dire ben
non il a été condamné six fois pour
antisémitisme alors que c'est quand même
le fondateur historique de ce mouvement
et je dirais nier les faits ça ça me
semble procéder je dirais d'une forme de
tout en précisant pour lui la ch n'était
pas un détail de l'histoire le sujet
n'est pas Jordan Bardella le sujet c'est
que quand vous êtes président d' un
parti politique vous assumez votre passé
vous avez le droit d'expliquer que vous
n'êtes pas à l'aise avec le fondateur de
ce parti et avec ce qu'il a pu dire en
revanche vous ne niz pas les faits enfin
c'est un fait de dire que Jean-Marie Le
Pen a été condamné six fois pour des
calambours douteux et pour des propos
raciste et antisémite donc voilà il a
commis une faute politique Gordan
Bardella pour vous je crois qu'il a
commis effectivement une faute politique
oui oui parce que tout le travail de
dédiabolisation en réalité on voit bien
que ça montre qu'il y a une forme de
malaise et que ce malaise va non pas
jusqu'à euh s'opposer à ce qui a été
fait mais carrément euh tenter de faire
oublier euh les fait et moi j'ai c'est
quelque chose qui m'a toujours frappé
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné on
doit euh regarder l'histoire telle
qu'elle a été faite quand j'étais
parlementaire euh j'ai euh défendu par
exemple sur les textes sur l'hérarchie
j'ai critiqué le général de Gaulle j'ai
critiqué la politique qui a été faite
c'est pourtant quelqu'un que j'admire
beaucoup mais à un moment donné voilà on
n'est pas la copie et c'est pas parce
qu'on s'inspire de quelqu'un ou d'une
histoire qu'on est obligé de reprendre
comme un bloc on est aussi capable
d'avoir son jugement critique Jordan
badrella qui pour le moment est donné
largement en tête dans les sondages pour
les élections européennes les
républicains n'ont toujours pas tête de
liste est-ce que c'est un problème non
ce n'est pas un problème puisque les
élections n'ont pas débuté effectivement
je peux comprendre que mais il y en a
qui ont débuté leur campagne à commencé
par lui oui mais est-ce que les Français
s'y intéressent enfin très honnêtement
aujourd'hui faire campagne alors
que je dirais la focalisation des
Français elle est sur la question du
terrorisme sur le risque de d'un
embrasement
je dirais en France d'importation du
conflit israélo-palestinien et plus les
sujets de pouvoir d'achat et de crainte
pour alimentation les sujets européens
semblent assez loin mais pourquoi vous
tardez temps à désigner votre tête de
liste François Xavier bami c'est pas une
évidence pour moi François Xavier bami a
une vraie légitimité il a fait un très
bon travail de parlementaire européen il
représente une droite antimacron je
plaide pour que les républicains soient
très clair là-dessus que ce soit une
liste d'opposition au président de la
République après nous avons blo alors
premièrement des élections internes
deuxièmement une donc qui ont lieu
mi-nvembre deuxièmement une réécriture
des statutes qui est en cours et
troisièmement un grand chambardement
avec notamment un changement de siège et
donc je pense que si vous sera désigné
comment votre tê en terme de
communication comme va la désigner c'est
la Commission nationale de l'investiture
je pensais que la formation était oui
mais bon alors donc c'està-dire c'est
Eric soti qui va décider ah non la
Commission nationale de l'investiture à
laquelle j'ai l'honneur d'appartenir
c'est 70 personnes et donc vous avez bah
effectivement d'abord
vous aurez d'abord la désignation d'une
tête de liste et ensuite cette tête de
liste proposera une liste et vous vous
vous personnellement vous aimera être
sur cette liste sans parler de la tête
de liste moi ce que j'ai dit que
pourquoi pas la tête de liste d'illeurs
moi ce que j'ai dit c'est que j'étais
effectivement disponible mais je j'ai
conscience de représenter une
sensibilité des républicains
particulière goliste attacher la
souveraineté national et mon combat
n'est pas pour avoir un poste mon combat
c'est que cette liste reflète aussi et
et son programme reflète aussi ce que je
pense être le je dirais le le l'objet du
combat pour les républicains et pour moi
l'objet du combat c'est d'expliquer que
nous avons une dérive fédérale voilà qui
est en train de vider les démocraties de
leur intérêt je suis contre le frexit
même si on me classe dans les
souverainismes parce que je pense ce
serait une grave erreur en revanche je
pense qu'on doit proposer un autre
modèle européen et surtout un autre un
autre projet européen que celui de
Monsieur Macron adossé à Madame
vanerleyen qui a fait quand même toute
une une série de de BOURD ces dernières
années et ça c'est une voix singulière
chez les républi ben en tout cas vous
trouverez moins souverainiste que moi
moi si vous voulez je je pense sur par
exemple sur la hiérarchie des normes je
sais que ce sont des sujets juridiques
mais je pense si vous voulez que tant
que les gens voteront pour des
parlementaires et que derrière des cours
à l'extérieur des frontières pour
expliquer que ce que votent les
parlementaires n'a aucune prise bon on
pourra avoir des débats sans fin sur
l'immigration si ensuite bah vous avez
effectivement une cour qui vous empêche
d'expulser tel ou tel mais est-ce qu'il
y a une place est-ce qu'il y a une place
pour une liste bamie pour une ligne
benami quand vous avez Jordane Bardella
Marion maréchal est-ce que vous redoutez
que les républicains fassent moins de 5
% moi je pense qu'il y a une place
d'abord pour les républicains pour une
droite qui soit attachée à la nation
dans un dans une tradition golise qui
défende une Europe qui ne soit pas une
Europe caricaturale et surtout surtout
une droite qui soit en capacité d'agir
efficacement au sein du Parlement
européen parce que on sait très bien
comment fonctionne le Parlement européen
qui est dominé notamment par le Parti
populaire européen il faut changer ce
PPE qui à la base était plutôt fédéral
et démocrate chrétien de l'intérieur
pour en faire l'âme de la refondation du
Parlement parce queon peut s'égosier à
l'extérieur la réalité c'est que Marine
Le Pen n'a pas d'alliés donc en réalité
les eurodéputés du rassemblement
national bien verront passer le train
pendant 6 ans et ça fait quand même
maintenant un certain nombre d'années
que la France vait passer les trains et
on voit d'ailleurs l'influence allemande
sur la construction européenne et le
fait que la France ne défend pas ses
intérêts il y a pas d'équipe de France
députés euré les républicains ils sont
un peu seuls au sein du PPE Strasbourg
mais c'est pour ça que j'amène si vous
voulez j'appelle plutôt les Français à
doubler le nombre de joueur mettre une
équipe de réserve et à nous permettre de
peser plus c'est sûr que quand vous êtes
8 au sein du PPE l'Allemagne vousête pas
de la même manière que si vous êtes 20
vous avez vu que ursola Van derlayen est
intervenu au campus de renaissance à
Bordeaux et qu'elle a été très bien
accueillie là-bas alors que c'est une
figure du PPE mais alors à l'origine
madame vernaleyen a été parce qu'elle
était du PPE a été soutenue mais on la
connaissait pas aujourd'hui vous avez un
bilan qui pour moi sur unès un très
grand nombre de points est très
criticable je vous pose la question
aussi parce que on a vu dans il y a une
interview d'éic vert dans la tribune
dimanche ce dimanche donc ancien
ministre de l'UNP ancien secrétaire
général des républiquain qui est passé
chez Renaissance l'an dernier et qui
disent dans la tribune qui serait
hautement souhaitable que la majorité
ELR et un candidat commun en 2027 est-ce
que pour vous c'est c'est envisageable
ou c'est une hérésie totale la question
c'est pourquoi
vous votre ligne c'est Laurent vquier
non
ENF Laurent vquier parce que il est
clairement contre Emmanuel Macron c'est
pas le renvoquer pour avoir le renvoquer
a pas de r possible entre ce centre et
la
droite quoi regardz ce que les gens de
droite qui rejoint Emmanuel Macron font
la longueur de journée il se retrouvve à
cohabiter avec Monsieur Sacha Houlier
qui qui est sur une politique qui est
sur une politique extrêmement favorable
à l'immigration enfin tout ça n'a aucun
sens
vous pensez que Gérald harmanin il pèse
pas par exemple mais Gérald harmanin
tout homme de droite qu'il est et qui
pourquoi ça fait des annésir Philippe
n'a pas pesé on va prendre les un on va
les prendre les uns après les autres
parce que Gérald daranin n'est pas
éedard Philippe dard Philippe c'était
quelqu'un de centre droit bon qui était
chez vous oui oui non mais je veux dire
c'est pas la même Gérald armanin
soutenait pas exactement le même
candidat que Édouard Philippe aux
élections je comprends plus à limite la
frange jupéiste qui a pu se sentir je
dirais accueilli ou hébergée par le
macronisme mais pour un Géral d'manin
quel est son problème c'est qu'il défend
des positions de droit très ferme mais
il est minoritaire ou en tout cas il
doit composer avec des gens qui pensent
l'inverse n'z pas le sentiment que la
majorité présidentielle pense de plus en
plus à droite et de plus en plus vers
une droite qui se une droite de plus en
plus dure ou pas du tout une alors je
sais pas ce que c'est une droite dure je
vouleis dire une droite intelligente une
droite lucide une droite ferme une
droite courageuse bah j'ai trouve pas
très courageux non parce que s'ils
étaient courageux ils enlèveraient
l'article 3 et la réalité c'est que
Monsieur Darmanin se balade avec avec
son article 3 comme un fantôme avec son
boulet et qui l'empêche de voler un
dernier mot sur l'immigration parce que
Marion maréchal a lancé hier un comité
pour un référendum sur l'immigration
elle veut un référendum d'initiative
partagé visant à stopper l'immigration
massive et elle vous invite à rejoindre
son initiative est-ce que vous allez le
faire bah c'est plutôt elle qui nous a
rejoint dans l'espèce c'estàd que Mario
maréchal Le Pen c'est comme la lumière
et et le son c'est-à-dire que la lumière
nous l'avons émise il y a il y a 6 mois
lorsque nous avons fait notre
proposition de référendum institutionn
sur l'immigration et nous avons
aujourd'hui le son avec Mario Mar le qui
arrive avec 6 mois de retard vous avez
l'argent ou pas vous la connaissez bien
vous étiez élu du même département
est-ce que de la même ville puisquelle
avait Carpentra sud et moi Carpentra
Nord est-ce que vous allez rejoindre son
initiative ben je vous ai dit je vous ai
répondu c'estàd qu'en réalité c'est elle
est en train de proposer ce que les
républicains ont proposé il y a 6 mois
maintenant je crois si vous voulez que
il faut ENF ce qu'elle propose n ne
tient pas la route parce qu'elle parle
d'un référendum d'initiative partagé on
sait très bien que les règles
aujourd'hui pour mettre en place grip
pas pour les millions de gens qui vont
signer ça il y a pas de problème enfin
quoi que je me rappelle pour ADP où
j'avais soutenu c'est compliqué de
d'arriver à à 4 millions de signatures
mais il faut arriver à un certain nombre
de parlementaires qui est beaucoup trop
élevé et donc à un moment donné c'est
pas je dirais sur ce sujet-l et c'est à
Emmanuel Macron de prendre ses
responsabilités bah alors là il les
prend il veut diviser par de le nombre
de parlementaires nécessairirees passer
10 moi j'appelle pas ça pass 185 à 93
j'appelle pas ça prendre s
responsabilitéprs ça fait partie des
discussions qui onuront lieu la semaine
prochaine à saintis là rencontre dans la
feuille de route qu'on abusse le seuil
du rip c'est très bien mais je rappelle
que Emmanuel Macron a été élu l'an
dernier élu pour gouverner le général de
Gaulle ne réunissez pas tous les 15
jours les chefs de parti pour leur dire
bon et maintenant on fait quoi et voilà
à la carte vous avez droit en ancré vous
aurez le droit de manger ça au plat de
résistance je vous propose un bon
référendum ou alors une extension sur
l'IVG c'est pas ça la 5e République ce
qu'on attend d'Emmanuel Macron c'est que
il prenne il illustre cette droite
courageuse intelligente et luci dont
vous semblez la fuelé il prend ses
responsabilités il fait un discours à la
nation il dit moi président de la
République j'ai décidé d'organiser un
référendum sur l'immigration parce qu'on
va arrêter d'organiser des concertations
pour décider s'il faut modifier la
Constitution pour permettre un
référendum qui une fois qu'il aurait été
organisé permettrait peut-être de
modifier mais quand il décide tout seul
c'est Jupiter et quand il vous consulte
il prend pas ses responsabilités mais il
nous a consulté c'est bon enfin je veux
dire ça fait 6 mois qu'on lui a expliqué
consulter c'est quoi c'est écoutez on n
pas besoin de de passer 6 mois écoutez
quand quand on sait où on veut aller
mais en réalité Emmanuel Macron ne sait
pas où il veut aller et il sait pas où
il veut aller parce qu'en réalité il est
partagé toujours le le en même tempisme
montre si vous voulez sur sujet de
l'immigration son échec c'est qu'il est
incapable de trancher vous irez les
républicains iront au rencontrre de
Saint- erti s'y rendra j'ai pas entendu
dire qu'éti ne souhaitait pas s'y rendre
maintenant c'est quand même en partie
vidé de son intérêt si toute la gauche
n'y va pas voilà donc sans intérêt mais
mais il ira en tout cas il nous a pas
dit qu'il n'irait pas oui enfin après il
faudrait pas que ça devienne à mon avis
une perte enfin une espèce de grand
débat de mini débat Emmanuel Macron est
très très fort pour faire perdre du
temps aux autresè question clarification
CIS que le mouvement et la France que
vous avez créé en 2017 est en train de
se rapprocher de république souveraine
présidé par George kusmanovic l'ancien
secrétaire national du Parti de Gauche
qui a quitté la France insoumise
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce cette espèce
d'attelage pouvez nous expliquer quel
est le sens de alors dansurs alors je
vous laisse responsabiler vos propos
c'est c'est un mouvement qui est un
mouvement souverainiste et issu de la
gauche on va dire chevénemtiste donc
d'abord sur les valeurs justement ce que
nous avons souhaité nous avons organisé
un événement en septembre les rencontre
de la souveraineté qui était ouvert à
tous les mouvements se réclamant de la
souveraineté et qui permettait justement
de voir sur quoi on était d'accord sur
quoi on était pas d'accord c'est pas un
rapprochement c'est une je dirais un
débat une discussion et effectivement il
y a des choses que nous avons en commun
et puis il y a des points sur lesquels
nous ne sommes pas d'accord parce que
nous venons d'horizon politique différ
c'est votre en même temps à vous merci
non c'est je dirais la volonté de
montrer que ce on n'est pas une chapelle
et qu'on est capable nous de discuter
avec les gens qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec nous merci julient merci d'avoir
été notre invité merci Stéphane à la
semaine prochaine on regarde la Une de
est France un coup de pouce de l'État
pour réparer ses vêtements c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci Stéphane
merci Julien on passe au club des
territoires